- Hello, suit sheep.
Welcome to the 7 Million
Habits of Highly Effective
Hampton Deville Employees.
- Habit number
911, it's important
to keep your professional
life separate
from your personal life.
- Even if you work side
by side with the person
that you have
secret feelings for,
it's important to not
ever let those feelings
see the light of day.
- No inappropriate touching.
Do not invite it upon yourself.
- [John] Do not do that, Kate!
- Or inflict it on someone else.
- Yes.
- [Kate] This would
be an example.
You would never do that.
- And I know it's wrong
because it feels good.
- Yeah, don't do that.
- Please don't.
- I like to think of my feelings
as living, breathing
human being.
- That is so poignant, Kate.
And in order to maintain
professionalism at work,
it's critical that you
bury that human deep, deep
under the earth.
- In a coffin.
- And no matter how
much they beg and scream
and plead to be let out,
you never kiss a coworker.
- You do not do that.
- Don't do that.
- We have never done that
- Never think about it either.
- Never.
Didn't happen.
- Silly goose.
- Yeah, so silly.